[Applause]
this is the benefit from going first the
chance to meet the candidates face to
face to ask them questions to test their
positions Iowa is not first because it's
important it's important because it's
first Iowa has been the first in the
nation contest since 1972 that's because
it's caucus process is drawn-out and
complicated presidential campaigns can
spark into life here or be extinguished
that gives people incredible power one
report suggests voters in Iowa have 20
times more influence than almost any
other state the weight and meaning of
Iowa is really supplied by our national
media establishment this is the first
time they have hard results from actual
voters and so it's used as an
opportunity to essentially understand
where these candidates are in the race
Iowa is predominantly white it's mainly
rural as few big industries essentially
it doesn't look a lot like the rest of
America there are plenty who would like
to see the first contest held in a state
that's more representative of America as
a whole but that's simply not going to
happen if somewhere were to move its
primary or its caucuses than Iowa will
move its own because the state law says
it always has to be first
the people here insist they take the
responsibilities very seriously in
vetting presidential candidates and I
just think that you know we make good
decisions in the past it's not always
when you want it's very important to
know that the people that are on the
first line for caucus doing are
knowledgeable and can represent
minorities throughout the United States
one experienced political watcher says
the people here know they're doing their
job for the rest of the country I will
say in terms of the diversity of the
state that Iowans care about a wide
variety of issues there's a lot of
issues including issues that relate to
the minority communities they get aired
in the Iowa caucuses so there's a brown
and black forum specifically dedicated
to giving candidates an opportunity to
air their issues remain the only major
country on earth not to guarantee health
care some politicians have skipped Iowa
complaining of its outsized influence
it's never worked out for them
they like it or not for the moment the
road to the White House goes through
here Alan Fisher al-jazeera des Moines
Iowa